[Música]
el aleteo de una mariposa puede causar
un tifón en algún lugar del mundo
bienvenidos al infierno también conocido
como el sahel el 20 de abril de 2021 el
presidente de chad fue asesinado en un
enfrentamiento con una guerrilla una
semana más tarde tres periodistas han
sido asesinados en burkina faso dos de
ellos eran españoles de repente todos
los medios están hablando de la región
del sahel la zona más castigada del
mundo se trata de la franja de tierra
que separa el desierto del sahara de las
grandes sabanas africanas el sahel es
tan violento como irak pero mucho más
pobre ha sufrido colonialismo
desertificación y ahora se está
convirtiendo en el nuevo foco del
terrorismo islámico y esta vez hablamos
de terroristas que podrían llegar a
conquistar algunas de las minas de
uranio más importantes del mundo es
decir que podrían llegar a conseguir
uranio con el que fabricar las llamadas
bombas sucias pese a todo esto eeuu está
retirando las pocas tropas que tenían la
zona cada vez se ven más mercenarios
rusos por la región y sólo hay una
potencia con un interés claro en esta
región francia y diréis pero que le
importa francia lo que ocurre en el
sahel y tiene que ver todo esto con él
efecto mariposa y lo que es más
importante porque debería preocuparnos
lo que ocurre en mitad de áfrica en este
vídeo te lo vamos a explicar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
hoy en día es fácil denunciar los abusos
que cometió el imperio español o el
imperio británico pero seamos honestos
ya ha habido una potencia colonial
depredadora esa es sin duda alguna el
imperio francés hasta los años 70 del
siglo 20 francia había colonizado casi
un tercio de toda la población africana
[Música]
argelia malí chad todas estas son
algunas de las muchísimas ex colonias
francesas durante más de siglo y medio
francia explotó los recursos naturales
del continente africano dejando a su
paso las sociedades completamente rotas
vamos ya a su lado los conquistadores
españoles y británicos habrían aparecido
los ositos amorosos y ahora siguen
haciendo lo mismo pero de otra forma
en la llamada franca freeze francia
quita y pone a los dictadores que más le
conviene y esto nos lleva de vuelta al
sahel y grace pero qué demonios es eso
del sahel pues se trata de la franja que
separa el desierto del sahara de las
grandes sabanas africanas una zona donde
es prácticamente imposible cultivar nada
donde las sequías son frecuentes y donde
ocho de cada diez habitantes viven con
menos de 1 con 90 dólares al día y si os
lo hemos dicho mil veces aquí en visual
político la pobreza está desapareciendo
del mundo sin embargo el sahel es uno de
los pocos lugares donde persiste y no
parece que haya ninguna señal de mejora
más bien todo lo contrario y no penséis
que hablamos de una región pequeña
fijaos en este mundo
viven más de 300 millones de personas
repartidas entre varios países
burkina faso malí níger chad y algunos
más para que os hagáis una idea de lo
grande que es esta región la distancia
de este a oeste es la misma que hay
desde madrid hasta nueva york pues bien
el sahel ha sido siempre pobre pero
ahora a toda esta miseria se le suma la
violencia miles de personas mueren cada
año a manos de distintos grupos
terroristas tanto al qaeda como el
estado islámico tienen sus franquicias
por aquí y su presencia es cada vez más
importante y todo esto explica noticias
como este
francia desplegará más tropas para
luchar contra los extremistas en el
sahel
a día de hoy francia tiene más de 5000
efectivos desplegados en el sahel la onu
lleva ocho años con la operación minus
ma para establecer la situación en mali
la unión europea tiene dos misiones de
entrenamiento y envía varios millones de
euros en ayuda humanitaria año tras año
pero hasta la fecha nada de esto ha
servido mientras tanto tanto turquía
como rusia están prestando cada vez más
atención a esta región así que la
pregunta que nos hacemos es qué es
exactamente lo que está haciendo francia
en el sahel de verdad es tan importante
lo que está ocurriendo en esta región
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes antes os presento la tan
política la newsletter sobre análisis de
latinoamérica que hemos creado junto a
la consultora first perspective
por sólo 5 dólares al mes
recibiréis tres boletines semanales con
el mejor análisis político y ya sé lo
qué pensaréis muchos porque iba a pagar
por información pues lo podéis ver más
con una inversión que como un gasto
tanto si queréis hacer negocios en
latinoamérica como si estáis buscando
una oportunidad de trabajo en este
continente flat and politics os
permitirá poner en contexto todo lo que
ocurre en la región tenéis toda la
información en latam polític puntocom y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
el triángulo del mal si el sahel fuera
un país en términos de población sería
el cuarto país más grande del planeta y
como os podéis imaginar esta región es
de todo menos homogénea hay muchísimas
desigualdades y diferencias si
comparamos por ejemplo la parte
occidental con la parte oriental así que
en el vídeo de hoy nos vamos a centrar
en 5 países del sahel central y
occidental
hablamos de burkina faso chad malí
mauritania y níger
estos cinco países tienen en común tres
cosas los cinco forman desde 2014 una
alianza que se conoce como el g5 del
sahel y los cinco fueron colonias
francesas y ahora son dictaduras
fallidas
es decir dictaduras donde el dictador ni
siquiera tiene control sobre todo el
territorio del país este espacio lo
cubren tribus y grupos terroristas pero
si todo esto ya osuna mal hay una zona
dentro del sahel que es aún peor la
llamada triple frontera o lo que
podríamos llamar el triángulo del mal
atentos a este mapa
como podéis ver hablamos de esta triple
frontera entre burkina faso níger y malí
históricamente esta región se llamaba al
dip taco burma pero podríamos llamarla
perfectamente el triángulo del mal en
los últimos años se ha convertido en el
epicentro de la violencia yihadista
sumarle también tráfico de drogas
tráfico de personas y tráfico de armas
para tener el cuadro completo y todo
esto explica noticias como esta
[Música]
francia aumenta la operación bajan a
cinco mil cien soldados para centrarse
aún más en la zona de la triple frontera
mali burkina faso níger y os
preguntaréis pero porque francia en
concreto tiene tanto interés en esta
región si seguís visual política desde
hace tiempo ya os podéis imaginar la
respuesta
durante siglos francia fue la principal
potencia colonizadora en áfrica y si es
cierto hace 60 años francia se marchó
del continente pero seamos honestos
nunca han abandonado del todo sus
colonias por ejemplo ya sabéis que
francia es una de las principales
potencias nucleares del mundo no sólo
porque tengan la bomba atómica además
son el segundo país del mundo con más
centrales nucleares para que os hagáis
una idea el 70% de la electricidad en
francia viene de sus centrales nucleares
[Música]
y os preguntaréis de dónde saca tanto
uranio francia para alimentar todas esas
centrales nucleares pues muy simple de
países como gabón o como níger es decir
ambas son ex colonias francesas
hasta aquí no tendría por qué haber
ningún problema verdad podría ser una
relación meramente comercial pero la
realidad es que francia ha estado
poniendo y quitando dictadores para
garantizarse el suministro de uranio y
de otros recursos materiales para que os
hagáis una idea la influencia de francia
en áfrica es tan grande que incluso la
moneda que se usa en casi todo el sahel
el franco cf está ligada al tesoro
francés
[Música]
ya os adelanto que en un futuro todo
esto puede cambiar porque los países del
áfrica occidental se están planteando
pasarse a una moneda propia llamada eco
pero hasta que eso pase
incluso los sistemas bancarios de los
países que usan el franco cf dependen
directamente de parís y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando a ver fonseca francia
no ha hecho nada que no haga por ejemplo
pues yo que sé eeuu pues si tenéis razón
pero como siempre decimos en este canal
el [ __ ] está en los detalles la gran
diferencia entre francia y prácticamente
cualquier otra potencia colonial es la
precisión por ejemplo reino unido-
colonizó la india y su presencia llegó a
todos los rincones del país es decir que
dentro de lo malo los británicos se
encargarán de construir ferrocarriles
colegios y de poner seguridad en todas
las ciudades de la india francia sin
embargo fue mucho más precisa que me
estoy refiriendo pues atentos a este
mapa
lo que estáis viendo es un mapa de las
vías de tren que existen en áfrica hoy
en día la mayor parte se construyeron en
tiempos coloniales como podéis ver las
vías de tren situadas en el sahel
occidental tienen en común una cosa
salen de la costa y llegan al lugar
donde están los recursos naturales es
decir que sólo sirven para hacer un
viaje rapidito recoger los recursos
naturales y volver a la metrópolis esto
explica que el sur del sahel tenga
trenes y que el norte no
básicamente los colonos franceses solo
se preocuparon por controlar las minas
el resto lo dejaron total y
absolutamente desatendido y todo esto
explica por qué por ejemplo mauritania
pese a haber sido una colonia francesa
fuera el último país del mundo en abolir
la esclavitud es decir que hasta el año
1981 era perfectamente legal tener
esclavos en este país incluso hoy en día
siguen existiendo granjas de mujeres es
decir granjas donde se en cort a las
mujeres para que cumplan con los
estándares de belleza tradicionales
y por supuesto a todo esto hay que
sumarle las sequías y el cambio
climático el desierto del sahara se
expande año tras año y según la onu la
temperatura en esta región aumenta 15
veces más rápido que en el resto del
mundo conclusión pues que quitando las
minas de uranio y de oro prácticamente
todo el territorio del sahel está
controlado por tribus los cuales por
ejemplo son una de estas tribus nómadas
que lleva años luchando por tener su
propio estado y esta es una más de las
muchas etnias que llevan años peleándose
entre ellas pero ella se lo que os
estaréis preguntando todos ahora mismo
porque es justo ahora cuando nos tenemos
que preocupar por el sahel porque europa
está mandando ahora tantos soldados a
esta región que es exactamente lo que ha
cambiado pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
guerra de libia hay otra cosa en la que
francia es distinta de cualquier otra
potencia la forma en la que hacen la
guerra mientras eeuu se gasta auténticas
fortunas tratando de reconstruir los
países que ataca francia es mucho más
pragmática
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la guerra de irak costo a la casa blanca
más de 700 mil millones de dólares y
diréis en que se fue todo ese dinero
pues en tratar de reconstruir el país
tras la caída de sadam husein cuestión
aparte si lo han conseguido o no sin
embargo qué pasó en la guerra de libia
pues justo lo contrario la guerra de
libia fue una auténtica ganga les costó
a los franceses poco más de mil millones
de dólares y diréis pri cómo es posible
que esta guerra sea tan barata pues muy
fácil porque los franceses llegar a un
perro corona gadafi aseguraron los
yacimientos de petróleo y se larga oye
pierre pero tú has visto la que hemos
liado aquí que hemos dejado aquí hecho
en un avispero todo esto de libia que
está hasta el estado islámico que
hacemos que no nos podemos ir a mover
llamar y pone aquí hermanita de la
caridad a que no tú aquí has venido aquí
a controlar lo del petróleo y tal está
controlado no controlado está yo lo veo
controlado a quien hay terroristas pues
ahora nos vamos para casa y diréis per y
por tío se habló ahora de la guerra de
vida pues recordáis que al principio del
vídeo hablábamos del efecto mariposa en
esta historia hay muchos puntos que en
principio no lo parece pero que en la
realidad están muy pero que muy
conectados gadafi tenía uno de los
ejércitos mejor armados de todo áfrica y
adivinar a dónde fueron a parar todo
las armas
[Música]
armas y hombres provenientes de libia
fortalecen la rebelión en mali hasta ese
momento mal y podía tener sus guerrillas
pero bueno saber eran guerrillas sin
apenas armamento pero de repente de la
noche a la mañana todos los conflictos
de malí pasaron a ser un problema para
todo el mundo por ejemplo os acordáis de
los tuareg los tuaregs son un pueblo
bereber del desierto del sahara están
divididos en 36 países y uno de ellos es
malí así que vamos a por otro mapa
atentos
[Música]
como podéis ver si hablamos de etnias en
mar y se ven muy bien esta división
norte-sur de la que hablamos la capital
bamako está en el sur mientras que la
mitad de la parte norte es la que está
habitada por los tuaregs pues bien los
tuaregs se habían intentado independizar
varias veces pero ahora tenían las armas
libias para defender su causa y esto no
es todo porque además del secesionismo
la guerra de malí tenía otro
protagonista el yihadismo una parte
radicalizada de los insurgentes tú eres
decidió actuar por libre para imponer la
sharía en toda la región hablamos por
ejemplo de grupos como ánsar deal y un
grupo islamista tuareg que se creó en
marzo de 2012 además tenemos por aquí a
otros grupos como al qaeda del magreb
islámico' movimiento para la unidad y la
yihad y los firmantes con sangre
en definitiva el tipo de gente que no te
gustaría encontrarte por la calle para
el año 2012 la situación ya estaba
escalando a una velocidad endiablada en
cuestión de meses ya controlaban el
norte del país pues son un país que se
llame a hawai pues este fue el nombre
que los tuareg le dieron a sus
territorios conquistados el gobierno de
malí por aquel entonces estaba contra
las cuerdas y diréis quién podía
salvarles pues sorpresa
[Música]
ya se une a la lucha contra los
islamistas de mali efe holanda el 11 de
enero de 2013 el propio gobierno de malí
había pedido ayuda militar a su antigua
metrópoli y ese mismo día los aviones de
combate con banderita francesa ya
estaban sobrevolando el sahel la
pregunta es de verdad ha conseguido
francia borrar el terrorismo yihadista
de la zona y porque debería preocuparles
el yihadismo en sahel pues preparaos
porque ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
un rompecabezas imposible desde entonces
el ejército francés sigue por aquí el
sentimiento antifrancés en mali es cada
vez más fuerte en francia también existe
cada vez más oposición a esta guerra y
es en este momento cuando os
preguntaréis pero y por qué francia
sigue por aquí no se supone que francia
no está interesada en reconstruir los
países que ataca punto número uno os
acordáis de cuál era históricamente el
principal interés de francia en exagente
exacto los recursos naturales si las
fuerzas islamistas llegaran a controlar
los yacimientos estratégicos francia se
podría quedar sin el petróleo de chad el
oro de malí o el uranio de níger
vale que ninguno de estos países es
exportador imprescindible pero hay un
problema acabo de decir níger tiene dos
grandes minas de uranio una está en
arlit y la otra está en la costa desde
hace décadas este uranio iba a parar a
las centrales nucleares francesas sin
embargo ahora muchos tienen miedo de que
todo este verano acabe en manos de
yihadistas y la pregunta sería podrían
fabricar bombas atómicas lo cierto es
que no fabricar bombas atómicas requiere
de una tecnología prácticamente
impensable para un grupo terrorista
ahora bien si que podrían fabricar algo
muy parecido que son las llamadas bombas
sucias
es decir bombas que tienen uranio y que
al explotar pueden contaminar lo que
está a su alrededor se ha especulado
mucho sobre el riesgo que podrían
plantear estas bombas sucias pero lo
cierto es que ante la duda es mejor
proteger las minas de uranio y eso
explica noticias como esta
[Aplausos]
ya está protegiendo la mina de uranio de
níger sin embargo este no es el
auténtico problema y aquí es cuando
volvemos al efecto mariposa la
inestabilidad étnica y religiosa en un
lugar remoto del mundo puede generar un
problema político muy pero que muy gordo
en francia
hay una cosa que todavía no os he
contado en este vídeo el sahel es toda
una bomba demográfica por ejemplo se
estima que para el año 2050 la población
de níger se podría cuadruplicar así que
tenemos una región cada vez más pobre
más violenta y con cada vez más gente
todo esto significa una cosa una nueva
caravana migrante y pensarlo bien
imaginad que sois un maliense o un
saviano a qué país europeo os gustaría
mudar os vamos un país en el que
controlas el idioma y lo que es más
importante vais a encontrar a gente de
vuestra comunidad y si hay suerte a lo
mejor hasta un primo tercero
exacto hablamos de francia según las
cifras del instituto nacional de
estadística francés más del 46 por
ciento de los migrantes que viven en
francia nacieron en el continente
africano y estos datos ni siquiera
cubren la migración irregular a todo
esto hay que sumarle la amenaza
terrorista en francia y entenderéis por
qué están tan preocupados por controlar
los flujos migratorios
y la pregunta es pero qué están haciendo
para evitar esta nueva caravana de
refugiados pues bien por un lado tenemos
toda una dinastía de misiones militares
primero en 2013 francia lanzó la
operación serbal una intervención en
mali avalada por el consejo de seguridad
de la onu 3.500 efectivos de francia un
año después serbal se dio paso a la
operación antiterrorista variant donde
cinco mil cien soldados franceses y 405
de otras nacionalidades acudieron al
sahel en 2020 la unión europea creó un
grupo táctico llamado tacuba todas estas
operaciones también han contado con la
ayuda inestimable de eeuu pero seamos
honestos francia nunca ha permitido que
la casa blanca se meta demasiado porque
pues porque desde el principio todas
estas operaciones fueron lideradas por
francia y no olvidéis que para francia
lo más importante es mantener la
influencia en esta zona y lo último que
quieren a este respecto son competidores
así que la pregunta es de verdad están
funcionando todas estas misiones y la
respuesta es
francia y eeuu están empeorando la
seguridad en áfrica occidental a estas
alturas parece que no va a ser
suficiente con una solución puramente
militar
además otras potencias como turquía ya
han enviado medicinas y mascarillas a
níger y chad para luchar contra el
commit 19
[Música]
gracias a estas ayudas turquía está
comprando muchas voluntades y todo esto
explica que francia esté cambiando la
estrategia de las intervenciones
militares ultra pragmáticas están
pasando a lo que podríamos llamar el
palo y la zanahoria palo para los
yihadistas y zanahoria para los
gobiernos leales a francia por ejemplo
podemos hablar del proyecto de la gran
muralla verde se trata de un proyecto
para crear una larguísima franja de
bosques y granjas que evita la
desertificación este proyecto se inició
en 2007 pero apenas contaba con dinero
conclusión pues que no funcionó pues
bien desde principios del año 2021
francia ha entrado a meter dinero y la
verdad sea dicha no han reparado en
gastos
la gran muralla verde recibe más de 14
mil millones de dólares para reverdecer
el sahel francia y el banco mundial
están en la lista de donantes pero ahora
turno para vosotros es que esta nueva
estrategia de francia va a servir para
evitar una nueva caravana migrante a
europa que creéis qué pasaría si francia
retirase sus tropas de un día para otro
en el sahel y conocéis algún otro
ejemplo de cómo algunas antiguas
políticas coloniales siguen
repercutiendo en el mundo de hoy podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual politics sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]